Speaker 1: What about Alexander from Ohio?
Alexander from Ohio. What's going on with you?
Speaker 4: David? Sir, can.
Speaker 1: You hear me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 4: I was wondering, with the millennial
and younger population of America leaning left,
do you think that we will, in a couple
decades or so, be kind of done with these
insane issues that we've been having to
deal with for the last couple of years?
Speaker 1: What do you mean?
Speaker 4: Well, just kind of like
the fact that everything is like abortion, gun
laws, these kinds of all of these issues that are
the most important things in politics today for
us. Do you think with the culture kind of leaning
left in the future, a lot of these issues will
become just more like we'll come to a conclusion
about them and then they'll become non-issues?
Speaker 1: I see what you're saying. So here's
the thing. I do believe that many of the cultural
issues from today are not going to remain cultural
issues indefinitely. However, the right, which
depends on fear and scapegoating to try to win, is
going to move on to something else. And then the
question is who then is further victimized? And
that is a scary sort of proposition. So,
yeah, I don't think the focus will be
what it currently is indefinitely. But then
it's like, who who will they go after next?
And I don't I don't know. They're going
to find someone to go after and to base
their cultural war around.
Speaker 4: So this does
all just go on essentially forever then?
Speaker 1: I don't know about forever and I don't
know about it goes on, goes on like this. But I
think the point I'm making is for the foreseeable
future, if it's not trans people who are the
target, it's going to be someone it's going to
be. And so we just have to be ready for that.
Speaker 4: That makes a lot of sense,
David. I was also wondering what you
think of Ohio, if you've ever been here.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I've been to let's see, I've
been to Cleveland and Cleveland. I wasn't huge on
its it was very Pyongyang like a lot of concrete
brutalist architecture where I was, but I might
have only been in one neighborhood. And then
I've been to Columbus, which was kind of cool.
Columbus had a good this was a long time ago,
but it had a pretty good food scene. And yeah, I
don't have any particularly hot takes on on Ohio.
Speaker 4: Well, that's good, because a lot of
people often, you know, make jokes about.
Speaker 1: Ohio, but I'm fine with Ohio
existing, let's put it that way.
Speaker 4: Well, I appreciate it,
David. All right. Thank you for answering
questions. I really appreciate what you do.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Alexandra from Ohio,
great to hear from you. Let's go to Molly
from Utah next. Molly, please welcome to
the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 5: Hi. I am I am very far left. I
sound like a socialist. Oh, like a libertarian.
Speaker 1: You're almost whispering.
Try to speak up just a little bit.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Let me adjust
the microphone. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: Yeah. So I wanted to, like,
bestow some hope to, like, people in general. I'm
a libertarian socialist, so I work with the DSA,
and it everybody always wonders like,
how do you get party changes? How do you,
like, get people to within a specific party? It
doesn't matter which one, but how do you get it
to basically align with your beliefs? And so the
Tea Party has to do the whole delegate thing for
the Republican Party, and that's how they shift
a lot of local leaders. And so the DSA did the.
Speaker 1: Hello. Hello. Okay. The DSA. Well, we
lost. Molly. Uh. All right. Okay, That's weird.